In a world that seems busier by the day,
productivity is on the
minds of many. But instead of downloading
the latest time management app or forcing
yourself to stay at work for hours on
end how can we use science to crack open
the potential of our minds?  Is their a
secret to being productive?  The first
thing to come to terms with is that your
willpower is simply not enough. In fact
some studies suggest that will power is
an exhaustable source, that can be
entirely used up.  This is a concept known
as the ego depletion, so instead of
convincing yourself to simply try harder
a more methodical approach is suggested.
The first step,
get started, it may seem obvious but
studies have shown starting a project to be the
biggest barrier to productivity. Before starting our brain visualizes
the hardest parts to come and instead
tries to simulate real work by focusing
on small mindless tasks. Luckily there's
a construct of the mind known as the Zeigarnik
effect which compels humans to
finish a task that they've already
started.
The Zeigarnik effect shows that when we don't
finish a task we experience discomfort
and intrusive thoughts about it, so
get started, now.
What about time management? Shockingly
when we look at some of the most of the elite
musicians in the world we find that they
aren't necessarily practicing more but
instead more deliberately. This is
because they spend more time focused on
the hardest task and focus their
energy in packets.  Instead of diluting
their effort over the entire day they
have periods of intense work followed by
breaks.
Not relying on willpower they rely on a
habit and disciplined scheduling. Studies
have found that the most elite violinists
in the world generally follow a ninety
minute work regime with a fifteen
to twenty minute break afterwards.
Instead of trying to maintain energy
throughout the entire day, breaking it
down into sessions with planned
relaxation is most effective.
But how can you develop the discipline
to follow this routine?
One key component is giving yourself a
deadline.
Write it down, mark it in your calendar
and you'll be much more likely to
complete your task.  On top of this, create
something called an accountability
chart to document your progress. In one
column write the time span and in the
other the activities you accomplished
during this time.
Similar to those on a diet who document
their food intake writing down your
progress allows you to realistically evaluate your work as opposed to
inaccurately assuming what you've done.
Furthermore tracking your progress helps
to avoid small mindless work.  And finally,
stop multitasking, well it may feel like
you're accomplishing more, studies show
that multitaskers are much less
productive. Instead
try and make a list at night of what you
want to accomplish tomorrow, this way you hit
the ground running with your action plan
and avoid trying to complete multiple
activities at once.  While you're at it
split up your large tasks into smaller
bite sized ones.  Your brain will find
these less daunting and it will make the starting
process easier.  With a clear goal and
action plan in mind, your productivity
levels can soar to new heights.
Want more tips and information on
productivity?  Checkout Gregory Ciotti's
blog, "sparring mind" who we worked with to
make this video.
We will link to the productivity article
in the description where you can find
even more information and be sure to
sign up for his newsletter which covers
other amazing brainy content. Got a
burning question you want answered?  Ask it in
the comments or on facebook and twitter, and subscribe for more weekly science videos.